Pokemon scarlet and violet are finally
out and they Mark a number of changes
for the mainline series here are 15 ways
to make the most of your time in paldea
number one go to school nerd yes Pokemon
scarlet and violet let you attend
classes take tests and befriend your
teachers there's nothing stopping you
from cutting class but completing
classes will earn you some nice rewards
like experienced candies
to enroll in a class just talk to this
lady at the front desk and you're good
to go it's worth revisiting the school
often because you will unlock new
classes as you progress who knows you
might actually learn something as well
number two go anywhere once you've made
it through the tutorial you are free to
roam paldea in its entirety however
there is no level scaling across paldea
this means that some areas will be way
too tough for you at the beginning I
still like to poke around some of these
high level areas but don't expect to
accomplish much if your Pokemon are too
low level the general rule of thumb is
that the further you get from a sagoza
the tougher gyms trainers and wild
Pokemon will be since mazagoza is on the
southern tip that means the toughest
areas will be to the north
[Music]
number three the map considering how big
paldea is you will probably spend a lot
of time looking at the map unfortunately
the map isn't great you cannot rotate
the map when it is fully zoomed out but
it's the only way you can see the
entirety of paldea meanwhile zooming in
all the way is the only way you can see
all the different shops and there are
lots of different shops
[Music]
number four Pokedex rewards like every
Pokemon game your ultimate goal is to
complete the Pokedex Pokemon scarlet and
violet gives you rewards for hitting
certain Milestones to claim those
rewards open your Pokedex and press X
for every 10 volumes you will get items
ranging from pokeballs to XP candies
goodbye fly
scarlet and violet has fast travel and
it's available very early on once you
find a Pokemon Center you can fly there
easy as that keep in mind that you can't
fast travel while indoors if you try
Oak's famous words will echo through
your head there's a time and place for
everything but not now
[Music]
number six hello Glide you might be able
to go anywhere in paldea but it's pretty
tough to get anywhere efficiently
without meridon or corydon's traversal
ability in order to unlock these you'll
want to hunt down and defeat Titan
Pokemon in the path of Legends questline
cloth is the easiest to defeat and
you'll get a speed boost ability however
I started with a different Titan and
managed to unlock surf at the very
beginning of the game
number seven free-fallen paldea is home
to some tall mountains and deep Canyons
fortunately for you there's no fall
damage if something catches your
interest deep in a ravine just walk
right off the ledge if you fell by
accident you can press Y and you'll be
warped back up to the cliff you fell
from
[Music]
number eight battle trainers it's true
locking eyes with another trainer won't
initiate a battle in Pokemon scarlet and
violet however it's still important to
battle trainers when you find them at
some Pokemon centers you can find a
league representative once you've
defeated a certain number of trainers in
a specified area they will give you a
reward usually in the form of a TM these
trainers aren't too hard to find so just
explore each area you visit thoroughly
and you should be fine
[Music]
number nine to rasterize Pokemon scarlet
and violet introduces a new battle
mechanic called terastalizing basically
every Pokemon in paldea has a terror
type some have terror types different
from their original typing when they
terastalize their typing can change you
can drasticize one Pokemon once after
healing your Pokemon up at a Pokemon
Center so use this mechanic sparingly
[Music]
number 10 Auto battles Auto battling is
new to scarlet and violet and it comes
with some advantages and disadvantages
let's start with the positives Auto
battles are quick and net you a reduced
amount of experience if you want to
quickly level up a Pokemon the best way
to do that is to find an area with
Pokemon that are slightly higher levels
than yours and make sure you have a type
advantage against them tap the R button
near some Pokemon and the first monster
in your party will clear them out the
downside of Auto battles is that most
pokemon won't evolve and new moves
automatically get filed away in your
Pokemon's move pool of course if you
missed the evolution window it will
still evolve next level up just make
sure it levels up from a regular battle
or rare candies the other constant fear
I have when it comes to Auto battling is
accidentally knocking out a Shiny
Pokemon if you see one press ZR to
recall your Pokemon and approach it
normally
number 11 surprise wild Pokemon although
you can't catch Pokemon in scarlet and
violet without triggering a battle you
can still surprise them and get an extra
turn the B button will let you crouch
and you can use ZL to lock on and ZR to
send out the first Pokemon in your party
doing this can also make it easier to
catch wild Pokemon
[Music]
number 12 move pools thankfully if a
Pokemon does luna move through Auto
battling you can relearn it by checking
the Pokemon summary page in the menu
every move of Pokemon has learned can be
swapped out on the Fly this includes TMS
if you've taught them some in the past
number 13 TM crafting Pokemon scarlet
and violet introduced TM crafting in
order to craft a TM you need crafting
components which can be found by
defeating Pokemon and Lake points which
you should earn plenty of as you
progress basically any TM you found
automatically becomes craftable as long
as you have the right parts
number 14 picnics picnics are also new
to scarlet and violet and they allow you
to feed your Pokemon sandwiches you can
set up a picnic basically anywhere and
make sandwiches as long as you have all
the required ingredients sandwiches can
increase your odds of catching specific
Pokemon spawn more eggs and even
increase your shiny odds
number 15 breeding speaking of picnics
breeding has been overhauled in scarlet
and violet now in order to get eggs you
need to have two compatible Pokemon in
your party and start a picnic if they
are compatible eggs will spawn in the
picnic basket on the ground over time
any eggs you collect will automatically
transfer to your Pokemon boxes it's
worth mentioning that there's still a
lot we don't know about breeding so do
some research on your own when more
information is available I plan on
revisiting this in a future video so
make sure to subscribe down below
there you have it those are 15 tips that
should get you started in Pokemon
scarlet and violet stay tuned to
Gamespot for more coverage
[Music]